[Música]
el mundo conmemora el 8m el día
internacional por nuestros derechos una
jornada que reivindica que nuestros
derechos no tienen nada que ver con
flores en cambio Esta es la fecha en la
que esperamos oponer de relieve las
deudas pendientes de la sociedad con la
mujer como sujeto de derechos que
podamos acceder a salarios dignos y a
los lugares donde se toman las
decisiones que no nos acosen que no nos
violen que no nos maten para expresar
esas demandas las colectivas lideran
marchas en todo el mundo Cuál es el
poder de la marcha feminista y por qué
los hombres sólo son Bienvenidos en la
cola de las concentraciones nos lo va a
contar Catalina Ruiz Navarro periodista
cofundadora de la revista feminista
volcánicas y primera invitada del día
Catalina tiene la palabra y buen día
Muchísimas gracias por esta invitación
Ángela Bueno hay una cosa muy importante
que va a suceder este año y es que lo
estamos viendo como el regreso de las
marchas feministas en Ciudad de México
por ejemplo recordamos con mucho cariño
Esa marcha multitudinaria que hubo en
2020 que de verdad era una una de las
marchas más grandes que hemos visto en
México
absolutamente desbordada hermosa
pacífica
y
después justo una semana después llegó
la pandemia y después de la pandemia
marchar ha sido muy difícil han sido
marchas muy mermadas ha sido difícil
volver a la organización pero lo que se
espera hoy en Ciudad de México es volver
a estas marchas multitudinarias y que
todas las mujeres salgan a las calles
ahora sobre tu pregunta de Por qué los
hombres deben ir atrás en las marchas
mira que esto es una petición que
venimos haciendo en las marchas
feministas por allá Desde 2016 que tiene
que ver con crear unos espacios seguros
que a veces son separatistas porque en
algunos contingentes hay mujeres que
fueron víctimas hay mujeres que han sido
Víctimas de violencia machista a manos
de los hombres y dicen hoy por un día en
este espacio entre estas calles y estas
calles de tal hora a tal hora quiero
estar en un espacio público en donde yo
no tenga que ver hombres y eso es algo
la verdad bastante válido O sea hay
muchísimos espacios públicos en donde
que no nos permiten a las mujeres eso es
algo que que termina siendo algo muy
transgresor Mira que los vagones del
metro no hemos logrado que nos den un
espacio libre a una a pesar de que haya
vagones rosas casi que en el espacio
público el único lugar en donde nos
permiten tener espacios solo de mujeres
son los baños Pero esto hay que decirlo
a veces ha degenerado en un problema
porque algunas facciones del feminismo
han llevado este separatismo a un
confirmó que que yo creo que no nos
conviene a ninguna que tiene que ver con
empezar a ser trans excluyentes y
rechazar a las personas trans esta idea
del separatismo que inicialmente era
para excluir de ciertos espacios a
hombres heterosis que son quienes tienen
todo el poder
se ha usado ha tenido un mal uso en
algunos contingentes en donde excluyen a
las personas trans Y esto es uno de los
problemas que estamos enfrentando al
interior de las marchas que tenemos una
gran división al interior del feminismo
entre quienes somos trans incluyentes y
Quienes no lo son por si las dudas
muchas de nosotras las incluyentes
pensamos que las personas trans también
han sido víctimas del patriarcado como
nosotras y que nuestra lucha es una
lucha común entonces esa es una de las
grandes divisiones que vamos a ver en
las marchas hoy en toda latinoamérica
por ejemplo bueno Catalina conversaba
con una compañera fuera del aire que uno
de 365 días al año Pues tampoco es tan
grave no que haya un espacio diferencial
para las mujeres ahora noticia que es
muy constante y que se repite cada 8 de
marzo es que algún camarógrafo reportero
termine expulsado de la marcha golpeado
en algunos casos y pues hay una
indignación terrible porque esto sucede
sin embargo nadie se pone a mirar las
guías de las marchas feministas Cómo se
cubre una manifestación feminista mira
cuando nosotros hacemos estas exigencias
a la prensa nos dicen cómo pero si las
fuentes no le pueden hacer estas
exigencias al periodismo sin embargo en
ciertos momentos sí si tú vas a mandar a
alguien a cubrir el congreso A quién vas
a mandar cómo lo vas a mandar vestido lo
vas a mandar en unos jeans rotos y una
camiseta vieja probablemente no
probablemente Le vas a pedir que se
ponga unos pantalones y que se ponga una
camisa quizás una corbata porque porque
aunque las fuentes no nos van a decir
que tenemos que hacer para ir tú a
cobrar cubrir el congreso tienes que
Mostrar un respeto a ese espacio tienes
que Mostrar que entiendas las reglas de
ese espacio que puedes comportarte ahí y
que por lo tanto puedes cubrir
lugar lo que está sucediendo en ese
momento lo mismo pasa con las marchas
feministas hay espacios en donde puede
haber compañeros periodistas hombres
cubriendo porque hay muchos contingentes
mixtos pero en estos pocos contingentes
que específicamente han pedido espacios
sin nombres heterosis no deberían ir
camarógrafos y entonces mira lo que
sucede siempre mandan a una mujer que es
la reportera que va a estar frente a la
cámara de esa si hay muchas pero el
camarógrafo y El fotógrafo son hombres y
entonces uno dice Por qué no pueden
mandar mujeres te dicen es que no hay
porque las cámaras son muy pesadas
porque la foto reportería es algo
demasiado intrépido y las mujeres no lo
hacen Entonces qué nos está mostrando
esto que hay un profundo machismo al
interior de las prácticas feministas si
tu medio de comunicación no es capaz por
un día al menos contratar a una foto
reportera y a una camarógrafa freelance
O sea si eso no lo puedes hacer por un
día
claramente tienes un problema de
machismo al interior de tu redacción y
por eso no entiendes que estemos
haciendo este pedido y eso creo que es
algo que me parece muy interesante
porque pone en evidencia el machismo al
interior del periodismo pensamos siempre
en el periodismo como un lente neutro
que le muestra las cosas a la sociedad
pero resulta que no es así tenemos
muchos sesgos machistas al interior del
periodismo que tenemos que corregir Y
esta es una petición que los pone
siempre en evidencia bueno Catalina y
además es pensar que sí existen mujeres
que hacen cámara Pero por supuesto y hay
muchas y pensar que aquí es la agenda de
las víctimas lo que cuenta no no la
agenda del medio de comunicación muy
rápidamente en las marchas feministas y
no solo en ella sino en todas las
marchas hay episodios violentos y de
daños a objetos en la vía pública hay
colectivas que defienden que esto no es
vandalismo sino acción directa
rápidamente qué es eso
Bueno yo quiero que entendamos todos
tenemos definiciones de violencia
diferentes para mi violencia es cuando
tú atacas y le haces daño a una persona
para mí no es violento acaba atacar una
cabina telefónica ni un cajero
automático ni romper un vidrio en el
contexto de las marchas porque lo que
las mujeres están queriendo decir es
necesitamos que nos pongan atención de
alguna manera Por eso se llama acción
directa las mujeres hemos hecho lobby
político nos hemos lanzado a como
candidatas públicas hemos hecho
canciones hemos hecho poemas hemos hecho
política pública y no nos escuchan pero
de repente rayamos una pared de un
cajero automático y esto le duele
muchísimo más al gobierno que las
muertes de muchas mujeres y creo que
esto se va a seguir haciendo en las
marchas hasta que sea necesario y bajen
los feminicidios yo no creo que sea
violento ir contra un cajero automático
cuando hay miles de mujeres muriendo lo
violento es que nos preocupen más las
piedras que las vidas mujeres y bueno yo
simplemente cierro esta entrevista
Catalina porque ya se nos acaba el
tiempo
recordándoles a nuestros televidentes
que estos movilizaciones se tratan de
una reivindicación Pero además de una
ira contenida y de una indignación
contenida por siglos de violencias que
estalla el 8m y que no podemos hacer el
comparativo entre lo que vale la vida de
una mujer violentada versus la utilidad
de algún objeto que está en la vía
pública ese Catalina Ruiz Navarro
periodista de la revista feminista
volcánicas cofundadora además de esa
revista gracias a usted Muchísimas
gracias por la invitación y nos vemos en
las calles allá nos veremos Gracias
también a nuestros televidentes pero
quédense con nosotros ya seguimos con
más de directo América
[Música]